thank you
yes all right
he's seeking one of Earth's toughest
jobs but first he has to face Earth's
dumbest blobs
Tim Scott may have the edge against the
view in smart but can he survive
whoopee's farts
time once again for
our view on The View
[Music]
oh terrible Republican presidential
candidate Tim Scott dropped by the furry
five earlier today and I thought the U.S
had a distinct policy Against torture he
took the opportunity to call them out
over crap Joy Behar recently said about
him specifically that he doesn't get
systemic racism which is like saying
Brian stelter doesn't get Ben Jerry's
that's racism after all she's been black
on Halloween
yeah
yeah but joy wasn't there on the show
apparently Mondays are her days off when
she feeds in the pasture
but that is that is convenient right
it's like one of my aunts dies every
time bran kill me wants to hang out
maybe Joy needs a full day to read or
hate mail and that's just from the rest
of the cast
so Scott had to deal with sunny Hosten
in her typical self-righteousness play
it I'm the exception right you're the
exception maybe even miss Whoopi
Goldberg is the exception one of the
reasons why I'm on the show is because
of the comments that were made frankly
on this show that the only way for a
young African-American kid to be
successful in this country is to be the
exception and not the role that is a
dangerous offensive disgusting message
to send to our young people today I will
tell you that if my life is the
exception I can't imagine I can't it is
but it's not actually 40 homelessness
and fifty percent of the folks in our
community 13 of the population ask the
question I know I've watched you on the
show that you like people to be
deferential and respectful so I'm going
to do the same thing
um
[Music]
[Applause]
more time to talk
and I thought Will Smith wouldn't let a
black man finish
if her IQ was half as high as her
smugness she'd be Einstein and later it
got weird after Whoopi Goldberg asked a
question and Sonny chimed in again
frankly my side of the island I think
it's doing a fabulous job of making
progress the question is how do we
measure that progress how is that well
let me just give you a couple examples
here's how it works that was me talking
to you so I'd love it
without the conversation come on ladies
sit sir sit sit yes so the only
African-American female chief of staff
was mine that's the most exercise
Whoopi's had in years
and sunny looks more frightened than
President Biden when he sees a flight of
stairs here's an idea let's try it again
with music
come on ladies
[Applause]
[Music]
it went so much better
all right we're gonna stop there uh cat
um you did you watch the whole thing or
just the parts that I sent you
obviously just the parts
is that I watch a whole episode of The
View no woman can do that unless you're
stupid but here's a job here's the thing
how can they call themselves
progressives when they keep saying that
nothing has progressed then it's on them
right I also I just wish I could have
what I could would have watched if I
could would have been Joy Behar watching
that yes and being like I totally made
the right call
it's not an accident that they had him
there on her day off when she was you
know presented herself as the you know
expert on systemic racism as a white
lady well she had that one Halloween
Where She Went Diana Ross and she felt
she was treated differently you know I I
also just
he also came off as just extremely
likable yeah I know that they booed him
when they heard certain things but it
was hard to watch that and get mad at
him or think he's a jerk so I think I
think maybe being in an environment like
that could make somebody very irritated
beyond the ability to do that but he
really pulled it off what did you make
of it doctor
um I would have won I wanted to hear one
thing that didn't happen people throw
around systemic racism it's like it's a
buzzword right what does it really mean
they asked him to Define it and I would
have liked him to use that as an
opportunity to get votes to say look we
keep telling you because based on the
color of your skin you cannot achieve
it's baked in the system as a way to
keep getting Democratic votes to turn
that around and say well if you don't
like that you haven't achieved vote
Republican right don't look at me as as
an anomaly you can have what I have and
sunny has and Whoopi has like is he sick
of being the token like flag bearer for
the race it's annoying there is this
underlying thing there Jeff when when
Sonny says that we're the exception
somebody should say why are you like
because there's something about they're
kind of saying like they're different
like condescending yes it is yeah it is
as a white man you know this all too
well that is true man we've been through
enough these last three years exactly
no I will say I don't know admittedly I
don't know a lot about Tim Scott but
just the fact that he got booed at the
view is all I need to hear
he's got my vote
in fact I don't take a politician
seriously unless they have been
ridiculed by 90s comedian Whoopi Goldman
yes exactly and she's the most sensible
one they're all crazy over there Kennedy
you were you you talked about uh joy and
and the nonsense that she'd said before
I think on this show certainly Greg if
not I'm not gonna shy away from this no
you're not we literally talk about
anything else no no I'm kidding no The
View by the way we have to say thank you
to the view for providing us within it
was a slow weekend for news right I had
to do War
so
the view just gave us like so much did
you see what's on Fox all the time it's
like we went it's like the Fox News went
to the view buffet and just started
scooping out uh going back for more
I do hope they I hope they have all the
Republican presidential candidates on
yeah I hope they have Nikki Haley I hope
they tell her she doesn't know what it's
like to be a woman right or to be the
child of immigrants I hope they have
Donald Trump on just I hope they blow
out all the commercials for that yes
you don't know what it's like to be 40.
but it this this was such nonsense and
we were talking before the show about
that that scary scene where Sunny is is
cowering and whoopies strong and loving
fart-covered arms because you know this
this wild maniacal man is going to LEAP
out of his chair because he can't
control himself yes he's got so much
rage so much Republican rage yes exactly
lean into them and strangle the very
life out of them yeah I think that
that's how bad the studio would smell
after that no it would be terrible I
just think Joy has to answer to not
wanting to be on stage with a black man
you know that's the systemic racism
that's the systemic racism totally by
the way they can't admit that there's
progress because if you admit there's
progress they can't tell Democrats black
Democrats that things are getting better
they can't tell because if you tell them
things are getting better then they they
won't like they won't still buy into
this racism stuff didn't Whoopi Goldberg
defend Ted Danson for doing blackface
for like a decade yeah because what they
yeah they were dating for a while yeah
but I did think she thought he was black
I don't know that makes sense yes all
right we must move on up next we got
beef with the new CDC Chief hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else